[Music]
rise is the problem that riot games just
can't solve
he's a champion they can't seem to get
right no matter what they do to him
anyway let's move on to the like seventh
or whatever rise rework they make the
same mistakes again
and again but they are one man down
there goes cloud it's a four on four so
far cool's going to come around the side
right go down the double kill
go go it is absolutely wrecking through
this seat take a look at that uh
stat with two dragon averages rockets
usually want to take one a lot later in
fnatic
well they're the ones who couldn't
contest this time around meanwhile
though steve is getting chunked out by
huni who's finally gotten rolling and
he's stunned up after the flash
hoonie follows him through and slows him
down
what the hell just happened
this rise is insane dude just as tsm got
the baron before
it's kind of one to the other and they
have to get they gotta go they gotta go
they're gonna try to end the game here
so quickly they're gonna try to actually
stop and haunts are gonna try to stop
the backs
and chase them down they have to walk
all the way up here he's gonna find
golden glue they are playing stop the
back game
now on to the nexus turrets round warp
has been the key
for tsm this game you're trying to throw
on the axis turrets turtle's gonna be
honest it's not even a chance to stop it
and for the last decade
ryze has terrorized the league of
legends balance team
rise is one of the most iconic champions
in league of legends
he's been one of the game's main mascots
since launch which makes sense given
he's named after one of ryan's
co-founders
rise has also become synonymous with
faker one of the best league of legends
players of all time
or just let it fall a little more
ambitious as well in front of the turret
frozen
very very low goes down himself still
made one last shot faker gets the double
kill in
gets himself out of turret range along
with ambition but
rise has also been a terror to balance
for as long as riot can remember
when riot has a problem with the
champion they'll buff or nerf them
changing small things to fix their win
rate
but when the champion design itself is a
problem they'll rework that champion
completely rebuilding them from the
ground up rise has been reworked six
times more than any other champion in
the game but the first couple of reworks
were pretty understandable given how
absurdly broken champions were back in
2009.
old school league players who started
around season 2 actually first
encountered the third iteration of ryze
which means that riot had to completely
rip him apart twice just to create
something that was remotely fair to play
against
many fans consider season two rise to be
the original prize he was the classic
scaling hyper carry
play safe early get your rod of ages and
archangel staff and become an aoe damage
dealing monster
he was a deadly champion when piloted by
the best especially
in pro play what is going to happen
to sonic killing elements could be taken
out elements is so low so is chaos
chaos that's one take himself killing
everything
he is taking elements out and that is a
shutdown
ryze floated in and out of the meta
though he could always be relied on as a
pocket pick in a pinch but at the 2014
world championship
rise became a premier pick once again
just not
anywhere anyone expected ryze dominated
the top lane careful is it a four of one
now that pulled him in
it comes go going though here it goes go
go go and gets himself
in there goes the focus there's gonna be
sun going down have they got enough
damage this is a tricky tricky fight for
omg
but okay go go damage he just tanks up
for days watch gets flagged down
one more shot lovely gets he gets the
reset jump back around
saving trouble he's going down the
aquifers is not going to be enough to
save oh
gorilla as well and omg clean up
with a four for one fight they are going
to be singing go going
praises for a long time here but omg
they take themselves into access the
canoeing go on this one
it is once again the goat going show and
he goes in zappacorn oh
no us there's not gonna be enough
doesn't matter doesn't care it's go
going to get himself safe
omg chance come on ring around in korea
as they take down the next stone they
turn on separate they take down zephyr
goon pulls them in but it's not enough
it's going to be a 3-0 clean sweep
ladies and gentlemen
osg have done it rise was too powerful
so riot nerfed his overload ability and
the pros
basically dropped him entirely he barely
saw play in spring
see this is where the problems with ryze
really begin
riot doesn't want to have this situation
where if they nerf rise becomes
unplayable because then they basically
have a blank spot on the character
select screen
and they can't just buff him because
then he'd be broken again which would
also be bad for the game
that leaves a rework as the only option
and that's a ton of
effort and usually doesn't go so great
with ryze
the 2015 rework focused on giving him
more interesting windows of power
based around his new arcane mastery
passive rise gained a stack of arcane
mastery every time he cast an ability
and at five stacks he became
supercharged
getting a shield while his ability
cooldowns became basically zero
unfortunately this all turned out to be
stupidly broken
and fans refer to this iteration of ryze
as machine gun rise
machine gun activated
machine gun is our outpost rise was the
most picked and banned top laner across
all major regions that summer according
to league pedia and
for good reason he was busted take a
look at that
stat with the two dragon averages
rockets usually want to take one a lot
later in fnatic
well they're the ones who couldn't
contest this time around meanwhile
though steve is getting chunked out by
huni who's finally gotten rolling and
he's stunned up after the flash
hoonie follows him through and solos him
down
what the hell just happened the rise
craze cooled down after playoffs but at
worlds
faker reminded everyone just how broken
the champion could be
then there's support in our top lane
right now mid lane also goes down the
flash engage from faker and there's the
room prison in there
all of the spells all of the time faker
the 1v1 against pawn
watching faker win a world championship
with rise made mid laners around the
world start spamming the champion
by spring playoffs rise once again had a
100 pick ban rate in china and korea and
north america and europe were not far
behind
and that trend continued into msi
because of the immediacy
of that baron here comes at the speed of
light and blitzes down
mmd that could be a whole lot more
there's still 20 second respawn timers
on three
clg are looking to push into this base i
mean sure smithy's down but it's still
only two members and neither have we
played
on the nl and it's practically the solo
kill shot comes in the last second
but that was all who he's doing as ryze
ravaged pro play
riot had to consider the monster they'd
created
nerfs were not doing anything anymore
and he needed another
rework ryze's fifth rework came in june
2016 just over a year after his last one
but this time the reason behind it
wasn't as simple as him
just being too op see ryze actually had
a pretty healthy 50
win rate in solo queue ryan's problem
was ryze's incredible skill ceiling and
the insane disparity between playing him
in pro play and solo queue
for then riot champion designer david
gappuro the goal was to keep his high
skill ceiling while still making anyone
able to pick up and play rise to do this
ryze's new reworks ditched the arcade
mastery stacking and stripped a lot of
the cooldown reduction out of his kit
in addition to tweaks to his q w and e
ryzen's new passive gave bonus damage
based on his mana and his new alt realm
warp created a portal which could
teleport ryze and his teammates to a
different part of the map
picks up elder dragon for the team
damage now the haunts are in the back
it's fence garen going down now piglet
has fallen the ad damage is gone
and they've gotten the dragon just as
tsm got the baron before it's kind of
one to the other and they have to get
they gotta go they gotta go
they're gonna try to end the game here
so quickly they're gonna try to actually
stop the haunts are gonna try to stop
the backs and chase them down they have
to walk all the way up here
he's going to find golden glue they are
playing stop the back game
now on to the nexus turrets realm wharf
has been the key
for tsm in this game turtle's going to
be
honest it's not even a chance to stop it
after the rework rises priority calmed
down
he was pretty stable for the rest of
2016 and most of 2017.
i say most because after riot decided to
buff him for some reason
ryze was once again at the top of mid
laner's priority picks for worlds 2017.
no way with a zillion ultimate just
letting it rip reduction
down saves the background response
might save the other end of it
what a play they'll find the ace levi
responds to the gm but that's not enough
[Applause]
in the back bang has to retreat from the
fight they're able to take down max lore
they didn't have minions when they
started the fight and they didn't get
much damage onto the turret
still trying to turn they keep losing
members faker tries to go to the back as
ignore stops him
with what he can in 2018 rise got even
stronger with the introduction of the
new stopwatch room which combined with
his ultimate basically gave rise a free
get out of jail card at level six as
well
rise in some trouble shock wave brings
him back xiaohu tries to turn this one
out with me
tom kench coming into the mid lane as
well brings here jackie love
xiaohu will be on a portal away now
that's in trouble but it gets taken back
by the rise ultimate rng disengaged and
ming's able to get out as well simply
because xiaohu
is untargetable that's the strength of
stopwatch rise there's no cow to play
even after nerfing that ryze remained a
strong pick for the 2018
and 2019 season and the disparity
between ryze and pro play and solo queue
continued to widen
even though the explicit goal of the
2016 rework was to fix this
there was still a huge difference
between a top level rise and
the average player's rise so this is
this is pretty big
let's go through them all and
essentially rises the problem of
and has for a very long time had the
problem of um
is great in pro is not great in solo
queue
um and so they want to essentially
reshape the champion
so in june 2019 ryze got hit with his
sixth rework
and at this point even riot were meaning
on it because presumably the jokes
helped them deal with the pain of the
monster they'd created
the goal of this rework was to nerf the
things that made ryze too good in pro
play and buff the things that would make
him good in solo kill
this resulted in ryze losing his rune
shield which is what made him harder to
kill in team fights and gaining a spell
flux that always
bounced which made it easier to hit his
combos this all proved successful on the
solo queue front
leaving riot questioning if any more
changes were even needed so the gold we
know the rise is
generally down like three percent and up
and lower kilos
like we know the direction is right i
guess we're just
curious of the magnitude because
we're curious basically if there's a
there's a correlation if the correlation
is strong between
elite performance and solo queue and
playability in pro
despite an initial decline in pick rate
after these changes rise once again
returned for his yearly soiree at the
2019 world championship
ending the tournament as the most played
mid-lane champion now here's the target
dash is forward
reckless is on the board he gets the
first of the frame but it's not the cost
of nemesis's life he didn't use the
flash reckless gets over the wall and
now the chase back chris continues to
move forward as doing b gets himself a
kill on 2.0 the kale ultimate did not
come down
sadly for ryze that was his last time in
the spotlight
at least for a while he basically
disappeared from pro play
in 2020 though as ls explained in his
patch rundown series
that had a lot more to do with the meta
than with ryze himself
when you have champions that counter him
like orianna and just other stat track
mages in mid
that make it really problematic for him
to team fight and when more and more
range is getting added basically to the
game because of the
champions being picked inside of the
meta then ryze also begins to get hurt
there and if we have a lot of these
melee
team fight group clumpy champions uh
getting nerfed over time um
it just begins to hit him even more so
he's not really getting any damage
the fact that ryze isn't broken right
now does not mean he's gone forever
though
ryze is like a living piece of code he
will always find some way to get busted
even if riot never
intended it and hey now we're in 2021
new season new items new meta if the
last couple of years have taught us
anything
it's that ryze always comes back
let's just hope he doesn't bring his
seventh rework along with him
nico's are very interesting champion
design i love the thing where she splits
into two and like the cl
and i like that she looks like other
champions like it's all good [ __ ] it
reminds me of um
what's that pokemon called zorro arc
because its ability makes it look like
another pokemon but when it comes out
until you hit it it's a it's a really it
was like very interesting competitively
like a hot minute i think